not crying you're crying shut up all
right i just finished the fourth book
in stephen king's dark tower series
wizard
and glass and let me tell you folks it
was good
it was very good once again i'm going to
structure this review
by first doing spoiler-free and then
discussing spoilers
wizarding glass picks up immediately
after the waste lands
which is good because the wastelands
left on a huge cliffhanger i believe
wizard and glass
did a great job of wrapping up that
cliffhanger
i thought it was a little predictable
but
it makes sense it was predictable in a
way that was like inevitable like okay
it has to be this way it has to resolve
and i was very pleased with it
now on to the bulk of wizard and glass
and let me put it in
into a film analogy if the gunslinger
is a spaghetti western in the style of
sergio leone
then wizarding glass is like a john
ford old school hollywood western i
don't know if that was intentional on
stephen king's part but that's the
impression i got because where the
gunslinger and most of the dark tower
series
is full of action and um very fast paced
this book is very it's a it's a it's a
romance
i mean it's a romance story the bulk of
the book
is a flashback it is very processional
it's very stately and it moves at a very
steady pace kind of i wouldn't say
leisurely but it
it really takes its time it breathes in
the pages between like
the first hundred pages which is
basically wrapping up the wastelands and
then
the next 600 pages the change in writing
style is so
distinct it's almost like you're being
hit with a wave
layered in long sentences and very
descriptive
and going through every scene in almost
a painstaking way
john ford movies if you've ever seen a
john ford movie are it's a lot more like
dancing than shootouts look at my
darling clementine
for uh an example so that's by
comparison
it's kind of wonderful and it's charming
and it's beautiful and i just have to
say like stephen king's writing
in this book first off you know he wrote
these books over a long period
of time so his writing is going to
change clearly but in wizard and glass
it's like
i could feel him trying to hit a
different register
oh my god it it works i will say when i
first when you first get into the
flashback
it feels like you're in slow motion for
a minute because you're you're off the
high
of the wastelands which it feels like a
high and then it wraps up so perfectly
and it's just like you're coming down
this roller coaster of intense action
you know fast pace chew slow motion
we're going to soak in the atmosphere
and the details we're going to
feel this romance story we're not going
to leave
any details spared we're going to
discuss every you know character in this
town we're going to explore
the logistics of the cattle is being
moved you know the horses
and how the horses are being moved
around and you're kind of wondering okay
will this pay off and it pays off it
truly does
the book delivers and by the time
i got to the end of the flashback
sequence which is the majority of the
book
i was kind of sad to be gone because i
had fallen in love with these characters
you know going into it that's going to
be a tragedy
still when it comes it's just it's so
hard it's so hard to deal with and you
just kind of keep
hoping as you read the book that somehow
it's going to change that somehow it's
this inevitable thing isn't going to
happen and that's what makes a great
tragedy i think that you know what's
going to happen
but still you hope right that's the the
flashback then we return back
to the frame story basically for wizard
and glass starts to advance the dark
tower story at the very end so if you're
looking for a ton
of momentum in terms of literally moving
on the path of the beam
this book isn't isn't that it's kind of
a
huge digression but it's really
necessary because there's information
that helps us
understand the story to come but also uh
enrichens the world
and the character of roland so with that
out of the way
wizard and glass feels the most complete
and like the most
perfectly constructed like you really
feel in the pages like this is a
master of the craft and it's kind of
awe-inspiring
any person who says stephen king can't
write a [ __ ] sentence
show them wizard and glass jesus like
get off your [ __ ] high horses people
and appreciate
how brilliant stephen king is as a
writer god damn it but his eyes never
left hers
and in them she saw some of roland's
truth
the deep romance of his nature buried
like a fabulous streak of
alien metal in the granite of his
practicality
he accepted love as a fact rather than a
flower
and it rendered her genial contempt
powerless over both of them
it's just beautiful writing and and it
takes its time it kind of luxuriates in
the language a little bit more and so
there you go
spoilers uh i'm going to talk about this
a few scenes
all right so a few scenes i just want to
discuss and maybe a few more complaints
because uh
i don't have a lot of complaints but i
will say the climax in the flashback
uh regarding the oil tankers um and
messing up with john farson's farson's
plans
whatever blowing up the oil tankers and
then going into the those were
great scenes however it kind of goes off
without a hitch
really it started to feel like nothing
can go wrong for them of course
i mean of course susan is burning you
know while this is happening
um which kind of gives it a dark irony i
love the scene and the finney when
all the horses and and guys are getting
sucked into this thing
it's just fantastic fantasy like that's
just i love
and horror i just love that scene and
good god
aria reya of the coos what
a character what a creepy
[ __ ] like that's a such a memorable
such a memorable character
i haven't encountered a more convincing
or scary witch
creepy as all hell from the beginning
and just gets creepier and creepier and
the way she has the
the the wizards glass that she just
becomes obsessed with it that she's
literally just like all she does is sit
in her chair looking at it and she's
like decaying she's like
peeing herself sores all over her body
and her skin like
jesus i really loved coral thorin
and eldridge jonas's relationship which
surprised me i didn't think that there
would be kind of tenderness between
jonas and coral and of course susan and
and roland's relationship was kind of
idealized but
in a very like very understandable way
people might not like it being sappy or
whatever but that's that's how roland
sees it and roland is ultimately telling
the story
if you hate romance like this is as
sappy as they come really but it's
honest and it's
it really reflects kind of young
fatalistic love
like romeo and juliet you know the more
i reflect on it the more
i appreciate it and the more i'm i i
love it
it took longer to get through than the
other books it was worth it because
there was a lot of depth
and emotion and heart and it really felt
like
king put his whole heart into this book
highest recommendation to
wizard and glass this series is
turning into one of my favorites of all
time honestly so
thank you for watching have a good um
reading
time day whatever you do with your life
like and subscribe if you
are into this sort of nonsense and yeah
have a good one